[Applause]
the unit till anti-lynching act was
signed into law on march 29 2022. it's
definitely good news but it does feel a
little surprising that it just happened
it's like finding out we just passed a
law saying you can't light a daycare on
fire like how was that not already the
law
the anti-lynching act actually passed
the house by a vote of 422-3
and passed the senate by unanimous
consent it sounds easy so why did it
take so long the short answer of course
is racism the long answer is racism but
with more details so
let's take a look at why it took
congress over a century to pass an
anti-lynching bill and why it still
matters
to do that we need to go back to the
beginning of the last century you know
when it was totally normal to name your
baby herman and people used to rock out
to this
[Music]
you think you can't twerk to that you
could talk to that
in the year 1900 the first anti-lynching
bill was presented to congress by george
henry white a representative from north
carolina now you might not be able to
tell but for his day and age this man
was a fox in 2022 he's a three but in
1900 he was an 11.
now to set the scene there had been
unrest in white's district which
included wilmington north carolina
wilmington had a mostly black population
and many black government officials the
black community there was filled with
doctors and lawyers and people who owned
prosperous businesses and if you've ever
seen this show before i think you know
where this is going it's the same
feeling you get when a white person is
about to give their thoughts on the will
smith chris rock slap it's gonna end
poorly
black families in wilmington became
successful and their white neighbors
were not having it so white supremacist
groups in the area published something
they called the white declaration of
independence which correct me if i'm
wrong here is just the declaration of
independence
anyway their version said that white men
had to be given black men's jobs in
businesses which is insane basically the
business community in wilmington was a
lot like the word bay created by black
people but as soon as it got big white
people had to find a way to ruin it
and that's exactly what they did a white
mob stormed through the streets of
wilmington shooting into the homes and
schools of black residents they
violently seized control of the
government and installed unelected white
people to replace black officials mobs
ravaged the entire city lynching
anywhere from dozens to hundreds of
black residents that is the environment
in which george henry white introduced
the first anti-lynching bill to congress
as a black man who had just watched his
constituents being lynched in the
streets and yet the bill never made it
out of committee congress refused to
even have the conversation when he left
congress a few years a few years later
george henry white would be the last
black person in congress for almost
three decades because you know the old
saying once you go black white people
throw a huge tantrum and don't elect
another black person for an entire
generation
might not be catchy but it's true now
that was just the first try after the
bill's failure it took 20 years before
another anti-lynching bill was
introduced into congress this time it
took the work of the naacp and a
missouri representative named leonidas
dyer dyer also had seen attacks on his
black constituents including the east
saint louis race riots in which 38
african-american men women and children
were murdered by a white mob
dyer's bill did it did actually make it
out of committee and even passed in the
house in 1922 but it was stalled by
racist in congress who claimed that the
anti-lynching bill was and i swear this
is true an act of legislative mob
violence which is insane that's not just
the pot calling the kettle black it's
the pot lynching the kettle and then
complaining about pan on pan violence
unfortunately the stories go on like
this for the next century anti-lynching
bills emerged every decade or two like
cicadas or revivals of annie and
and just like annie there were a lot of
white guys embarrassing themselves by
being on the wrong side of history
mr warbucks you are an aging bald guy
constantly hitting on your much younger
assistant you are a cliche and a walking
sexual harassment lawsuit find a woman
who isn't your employee and stop asking
everybody to call you daddy you freaking
creep
the fact is almost 200 anti-lynching
bills were introduced in the first half
of the 20th century seven presidents
petitioned congress to end lynching
sometimes the bills would actually pass
the house but they always got blocked by
the senate and by the way you know how i
know all that because it's from the text
of a resolution the senate passed in
2005 apologizing for the fact that they
never passed an anti-lynching bill
that's right they passed a resolution
apologizing for not passing an
anti-lynching bill but they still didn't
pass an anti-lynching bill that's nuts
men
it's like lifeguards apologizing to
someone for all the shark attacks while
the shark is still chewing off their leg
get your priorities straight
now you've probably noticed that i
haven't really gotten into the details
of lynching in this piece well that's
because once you talk about exactly what
happened it's hard to make jokes but the
details matter
more than 4 000 people were lynched in
the united states between 1882 and 1968
and 99 of perpetrators escaped state or
local punishment the equal justice
initiative describes some of these
lynchings as carnival-like events where
vendors sold food photographers printed
postcards and victims clothing and body
parts were given out as souvenirs
lynching has basically been an open moon
for our country yes it hurts to deal
with it but it will get so much worse if
we don't then naacp defines lynching as
the public killing of an individual who
has not received any due process so yeah
that includes our ancestors who were
hanged from trees but it also includes
modern day black people who were
murdered while they were taking out
their wallet wearing a hoodie or jogging
in their neighborhood or just minding
their own dang business
the emmett till anti-lynching act was
signed into law last month all it took
was 200 attempts
122 years and thousands upon thousands
of lynchings i'm glad it finally got
passed but we have to remember exactly
how we got here
let's talk about museums a great place
to go if you want to seem classy while
looking at naked people
our show is filmed in new york city
which is home to
some of the best museums in the world
like the met the museum of modern art
the guggenheim and of course the whitney
which i recently discovered is not a
shrine to whitney houston
i wanted to dance with somebody while
security guard was all like man we're
gonna have to ask you to leave and that
is fair
but as much as i love museums it's
important to recognize that many of them
have some real issues as i mentioned the
yale university art gallery recently had
to surrender a bunch of its artifacts to
law enforcement because they're being
investigated as stolen goods the art
allegedly came from a smuggling ring
that was responsible for the theft of
objects valued at more than 145 million
dollars
so even though the museums or
foundations paid for the artifacts it
turns out they don't actually own them
it's like if a guy stole my car and then
sold it to someone else the new owners
still have to give me back my car and
they should also have to detail it
because it's full of crumbs
so this is a really clear-cut case a guy
allegedly stole a bunch of stuff and
when people realized it the museums had
to give the stuff back but what if
instead of one person it was entire
countries doing the stealing and what if
museums have known for decades that they
were displaying stolen goods because
that's actually what's going on with
museums all over the world
to explain let me introduce you to the
royal museum for central africa in
belgium i know i just heard myself say
those words too
yup that's not where a museum about
africa belongs and the more you think
about it the worse it gets so people
from belgium went to africa looked
around and decided what's important then
they stole it put it in a museum and
showed it to their little friends
that's why when you watch black panther
some people think eric killmonger is the
villain and some people think he's the
guy making some good points
now
a little background here
yeah i know i cheered for him too in the
theater
but mostly for the haircut his hair is
untouchable now a little background here
back in the 1800s belgium was run by a
guy named king leopold ii on a side note
that man could absolutely go to a
hipster party in brooklyn tonight and
not stand out in any way
now this belgian hipster here decided he
wanted part of africa for himself so he
took it and because he obviously didn't
understand the concept of irony he named
it the congo free state which is a
little bit like calling chuck e cheese
the restaurant where no one ever pees in
the ball pit
it's just false advertising now leopold
looted and destroyed everything he came
into contact with in africa and because
of his brutality about half of the
congolese population died then after
stealing everything he could from the
african people he hired an architect to
build you guessed it the royal museum
for central africa then proceeded to
fill it with the stuff they stole from
the africans whose homes and families
they had destroyed and that's the museum
still sitting there today which is
insane that place has more of a haunted
legacy than the basement and get out
now
obviously the belgian museum is an
extreme example but museums all over the
world are proudly displaying stuff that
was stolen from other cultures which
isn't that surprising it turns out
people in egypt weren't like yeah girl
take my ancestors mummified body and let
second graders get peanut butter all
over it on a field trip
but however bad you're thinking all this
is it's actually worse because according
to unesco currently 90 to 95 of
sub-saharan cultural artifacts are
housed outside of africa that's like
finding out 95 of the real housewives in
atlanta live in duluth now
part of you might be saying but isn't it
good for people to see artifacts from
other cultures aren't these museums
doing a service and the answer is sure
sort of but even if you're doing
something good you don't get to do it
with stolen stuff remember when someone
stole my car earlier even if the new
owners are really nice people who are
using it to drive a bunch of nuns to
choir practice it is still not okay but
it is a fantastic idea for a sister act
sequel
now
i'm not saying you can't have objects
from other cultures in your museums or
that it's not important to be exposed to
art from other places but we do have to
find out where those objects came from
return some artifacts to their proper
owners and display others in their
appropriate context and the good news is
many museums today are really trying to
improve the royal museum for central
africa even closed down for a few years
to try to provide better context for
their displays the museum of men in san
diego announced that they would no
longer display human remains without
tribal consent which is good news but
also oh my god they were doing that that
is the most disturbing san diego related
news since we lost this woman
where is she
carmen for the love of god why can't you
just settle down
but
there's another way to make sure that
art
from people of color is ethically
sourced get it straight from artists
let's showcase more contemporary art
from artists of color and finally
museums need more people of color in
leadership positions according to a 2015
study only 16 percent of leadership
positions at art museums are held by
people of color and it's not acceptable
to have museum leadership that is only
slightly more diverse than the cast of
young children
museums have a rough past but they can
have a bright future many of them have
the power and wealth necessary to start
righting their wrongs and to establish a
more equitable arts industry so it's
time for them to step up and if they
want to start with the whitney houston
exhibit at the whitney
i wouldn't be mad because i believe the
children are our future this has been
how did we get here
police shootings are one of those things
you need to talk about even though you
don't really want to like prostate
health or the fact that mamma mia is
really just a musical episode of mori
white privilege is having three men who
might be your baby daddy and still
somehow getting played by meryl streep
so tonight we're not going to go into
the details of the latest horrific
police shooting instead we'll step back
and talk about a bigger question
why don't black people just comply with
the police now there are a million
reasons why a person might not comply in
any given situation but we are only
going to focus on two okay the first is
easy when black people encounter the
police they're often terrified if you're
a black person in america you've seen a
million viral videos of black people
being murdered by the police so when you
see the police even if you've done
nothing wrong you can feel like you are
in danger and when you're in danger you
want to get out of danger which is why
running can seem like a good option now
it can be hard for some white people to
understand being scared of cops maybe
in your life the police have always been
there to help you and it's hard to
believe that that's not true for
everyone it's like finding out that the
life jacket you use to keep you afloat
is actually a lead vest when put on
someone else and for black people the
different treatment by police isn't just
perception it's reality findings from
new york city's stop and frisk data
shows that compared to white residents
black residents are 17 percent more
likely to experience police use of hands
18 percent more likely to be pushed into
walls or the ground 24 percent more
likely to have a weapon pointed at them
and 25 more likely to be pepper sprayed
or hit by a baton so it makes perfect
sense that black people are fearful of
police and you act irrationally when you
think something is going to cause you
pain it's the same reason i scream every
time i see a hot comb ah my ear
and it gets worse according to a 2019
study black men are more than three
times more likely to be killed by police
over the course of their lifetime than
white men so when a black man gets
stopped by police and runs that's
actually pretty rational but if it's
still hard for white people to
understand here's another way to think
about it
what if black people react to police the
same way white people react to black
people
studies have repeatedly shown that white
people perceive black people as more
violent and more likely to commit crimes
even though that's not true in one study
where white participants were shown a
slideshow of random people's faces black
males were seen as more threatening than
white males which is horrible the only
time looking at a face should be
threatening is when you come across a
co-worker on hinge do you swipe right to
be nice do you swipe left to make it
less awkward
neither you quit your job and you leave
the country
but the racism doesn't stop at faces a
university of wisconsin study found that
when people consider how dangerous a
neighborhood is they don't base it on
the crime rate they base it on how much
of the population is young black men
that's right if there are young black
men then it is automatically dangerous
which is insane if that were accurate
the scariest place in america would have
been the set of a different world and
hey feelings are just feelings except
for one tiny thing when white people
feel like they're in danger they call
the police those very same police who
are killing black men at over three
times the rate of white men
white people love calling the cops so
much you would think they'd have a punch
card where the tenth call gets them a
free sandwich and let's be honest maybe
there is a certain kind of white person
that just likes to stir things up
who am i thinking of sophie
girl
you invited all three dads to a weird
island when you could have just sent
them an email and you didn't even tell
your mom girl you don't want a wedding
you want drama
now it's important to note that white
people don't call the police on everyone
one study of a mostly white community in
austin texas found that when residents
saw a suspicious person who was black
they called the police 60 of the time
and only 10 percent of the time when
they were white
basically white people decide black
people are dangerous so they call the
cops black people understand the
inherent danger of interacting with cops
so they freak out and when they freak
out the cops decide they're dangerous
it's a cycle of fear that keeps leading
back to black people getting killed but
all this is just part of the reason why
a black person might not comply with the
police
the second part of that is complying
doesn't guarantee your safety since 2015
625 black people were running away from
the police when they were shot and
killed which is terrifying but even
scarier
875 of them weren't the fact is
sometimes running away gets you killed
and sometimes staying still also gets
you killed now i'm a black lady who grew
up in omaha nebraska i do not have the
time to tell you about all my police
run-ins
wait maybe i do
those mother have pulled a gun on me
multiple times a gun on this
so the next time someone asks why black
people don't just comply with the police
feel free to tell them exactly how we
got here
tonight we're going to talk about foster
care so just so we're all on the same
page
foster care is when for any number of
reasons a kid is cared for by the state
instead of by their parents foster care
is not a secret system to care for the
safety and security of broadway legend
sutton foster
now foster care is important we need a
child welfare system to take kids out of
dangerous and abusive homes and keep
them safe but it's also important to
point out that the system is not the
same for everyone for example in los
angeles county black kids account for
only 7 percent of the population but are
24
of child welfare services population
which is insane black people haven't
been this overrepresented since tv shows
figured out they could cast us as
therapists
500 black therapists on tv
three in real life
now
those numbers mean there are a lot of
black kids who are being taken from
their families and removing black people
from their homes obviously isn't new to
america it's the foundation of slavery
and also what happens early on in most
seasons of the bachelor girl
you were never going to get to stay in
that house
but
in real life our country has a long
history of taking kids from their
families and it's not just black kids
all the way back to the late 1800s
hundreds of thousands of native
americans and indigenous children were
taken from their homes so that they
could be quote unquote civilized by
white people now just a reminder in the
1800s white people were forcing women to
wear these
also in the 1800s a white guy and i
swear i'm not making this up patented
this actual mousetrap with a loaded gun
that's real so honestly civilized white
people had so many bad ideas it's
amazing there are any left
now
the trend of taking away native kids to
live with white people continued for
decades in studies from 1969 and 1974
the association on american indian
affairs found that 25 to 35 percent of
all native children had been separated
from their families and put into the
foster care system or adopted and 90
were placed in non-indian homes and
that's just horrifying
uprooting a kid and placing them with
someone of a totally different
background should be a last resort
unless that kid is a scrappy redheaded
orphan
she'll do fine and she'll make you
realize you're in love with your
secretary
now part of you might be saying hey
maybe these native kids were actually
sent to places that were safer
i wish that were true unfortunately the
reality is many of them were sent to
schools where they were treated so
poorly that thousands of them died from
abuse and poor living conditions the
last of those schools didn't close until
the late
1990s which is shocking i thought the
worst thing happening in the 90s was
blues traveler
that [ __ ] was fine for like one or two
songs but this band went on multiple
tours and that is unacceptable
now things have gotten better since then
but even today native children are four
times more likely to be removed from
their families than white children are
from theirs so the question is why
why are black and native children being
removed from their homes so much more
than white kids well the first reason is
easy it's because they're being
investigated more often according to a
recent study in the american journal of
public health half of black children as
well as half of native american children
experienced a child protective services
investigation at some point in the first
18 years of their lives 18 years of
getting the run around oh run around
i take it back blues traveler is
actually pretty great
but hey maybe the investigations are
necessary after all we don't want a
child staying in an abusive home but
here's the thing the overwhelming
majority of child removals do not even
allege abuse in fact it actually turns
out that most charges against parents
have to do with one thing poverty that's
right people are literally having their
children taken away because they are
poor which is terrible if money made you
a good parent then succession would be a
comedy about four well-adjusted kids
now
foster care agencies have little
incentive to fix things that's at least
partially because america has
started using privatized foster care
that's right and maybe the most
terrifyingly american thing ever our
country has turned taking kids away from
their parents into a business and the
more kids in the system the more that
business profits unsurprisingly it ain't
going well a bipartisan congressional
report found that for-profit foster care
agencies had quote abuse neglect and
system failures at every level which by
the way is also the official slogan for
the catholic church
the good news is that
every everybody went
i see i remember what you're talking
about
the good news is there are some
solutions counties in california and new
york have been trying something called a
blind removal program and no it's not to
remove the blinds from your white
neighbor that she uses to peek through
while she's calling the police
looks like they're having some sort of
cookout and they're using a suspicious
substance called seasoning i'm going to
call 9-1-1
blind removal is actually a program
where caseworkers don't disclose the
race of a family when making decisions
about whether or not to remove the
children and so far it seems to help out
a lot new york's nassau county reported
that five years after removing race from
the deliberations 21
of children in foster care were black
compared with 57 before blind removal
which makes it pretty clear that a whole
lot of black kids were being removed
from their homes for no other reason
than the fact that they were black
the fact is we need to find a way to
protect black and native kids from abuse
while also removing the bias from the
system now that means taking race out of
the equation and also telling our
government to stop the privatization of
foster care oh and last but not least we
need to get some more black therapists
because these kids are going to need
them this has been how did we get here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you